en los vídeos pasados estábamos
analizando cómo resolver ecuaciones de
segundo grado pero factor izando en esta
ocasión me quiero tomar una ecuación de
segundo grado pero no la voy a resolver
factor izando voy a utilizar otra
técnica así que vamos a poner la
ecuación de segundo grado vamos a
resolver tengo 4 x + 1 todo esto elevado
al cuadrado menos 8 igual a 0 es justo
esto lo que yo quiero resolver y bueno
la vez pasada lo que hacíamos era
resolver este binomio al cuadrado
perfecto y después restarle 8 ya lo que
nos quedaba intentar factorizar los para
que nos quedara algo de la forma x menos
alguno por x menos otro algo igual a
cero y después decíamos a bueno como
estos dos son iguales a cero pues o el
primero es cero o el segundo cero y así
obtenemos las raíces en esta ocasión no
quiero hacer eso lo que quiero hacer es
teniendo esta ecuación cuadrática que yo
tengo aquí y date cuenta que es una
cuestión cuadrática porque la equis que
me va a quedar está elevada al cuadrado
lo quiero resolver por otro método así
que lo primero que voy a hacer es
sumarle 8 a ambos lados de la ecuación
de tal manera que del lado izquierdo
me queda 4 x más uno elevado al cuadrado
porque este 8 y este 8 se cancelan se
van y del lado derecho me queda
solamente 8 positivo dicho de otra
manera lo que hice fue pasar el menos 8
del otro lado de la ecuación para que me
diera un 8 positivo a continuación lo
que voy a hacer sacar la raíz cuadrada
de ambos lados de la ecuación y fíjate
que atrás lo que voy es despejar a x mi
idea en esta ocasión es tratar de
despejar a x por lo tanto si yo está con
la raíz cuadrada a la primera parte de
esta ecuación es decir a mi lado
izquierdo el cuadrado con la raíz se
cancelan mientras que del otro lado me
queda la raíz cuadrada de 8 pero
recuerda que es positiva y negativa
cuando sea con la raíz cuadrada tiene
dos posibles valores uno positivo y uno
negativo y bueno esta raíz cuadrada de 8
lo voy a escribir de la siguiente manera
va a ser 4 por 2 4 por 2
es lo mismo que 8 y lo estoy escribiendo
así no para que te confundas sino para
que se puedan eliminar algunas raíces
entonces aquí tengo 4 x + 1 y del otro
lado me queda más menos la raíz cuadrada
de 4 por 2 pero esto es lo mismo que dos
veces la raíz de 2 más
sí sí sí más o menos 2 veces la raíz de
2 y esto es porque cuando yo tengo dos
números multiplicándose adentro de una
raíz esto es lo mismo que tomar la raíz
de cada uno de los factores entonces me
queda la raíz de 4 que es 2 y la raíz de
2 que como no es exacta la voy a dejar
como raíz de 2 entonces tengo 2 raíz de
2 positiva y negativa recuerda que
tenemos 2 raíces cuando sacamos raíz
cuadrada y ahora si lo que voy a seguir
haciendo es despejando a x por lo tanto
me queda que 4x más uno es igual a 2
raíz de 2 o en su dado caso 4x más uno
es igual a menos 2 raíz de 2 es decir la
raíz negativa
puedo hacerlo de esta manera separando
cada una de las raíces o podemos seguir
trabajando con el signo + - y resolver
esta ecuación voy a seguir haciéndolo de
las dos maneras para que veas que
llegamos al mismo resultado pero al
final lo más importante es que tú te
sientas cómodo con tus resultados a
continuación voy a restar menos uno de
ambos lados de la ecuación y me queda 4x
de este lado y de este lado me queda
menos 1 + menos la raíz de 2 porque
fíjate que el menos 1 no se puede operar
con dos veces la raíz de 2 debido a que
no
cuánto equivale la raíz de dos
exactamente entonces me queda 4x es
igual a menos 1 + menos la raíz de 2 de
igual manera aquí lo único que estoy
pasando es el menos uno del otro lado
restando estaba sumando va a pasar del
otro lado restante me queda menos uno
más dos veces la raíz de dos en su dado
caso 4x es igual a menos uno menos dos
veces la raíz de 24 x es igual a menos
uno menos dos veces la raíz de dos
recuerda que en esta ocasión estamos
trabajando las dos raíces por separado
ya que estoy trabajando las dos raíces
juntas con este + - y bueno si te das
cuenta lo que me falta es pasar el 4 el
4 está multiplicando al x entonces lo
voy a pasar dividiendo por lo tanto voy
a dividir todo entre 44 entre 4 me da
uno y se van y del otro lado me queda
menos 1 más menos 2 veces la raíz de 2
entre 4 y ya con esto tengo a la equis
despejada este sería mi resultado si
quiero dar el resultado con mis raíces
juntas o en su dado caso si quiero
separar mis raíces
me quedaría menos 12 veces la raíz de 2
entre 4 o en su dado caso la otra raíz
me va a quedar menos 1 - 2
es la raíz de 2 entre 4 lo único que
hice fue pasar el 4 dividiendo y bueno
aquí ya tengo las 2 raíces de esta
ecuación cuadrática con la que empecé ya
explícitas lo que me gustaría ver es que
en efecto cumplan con que si son raíces
de esta ecuación cuadráticas es decir
vamos a verificar que lo que hicimos
está bien y para eso voy a agarrar una
raíz voy a agarrar la raíz positiva de
igual manera podemos tomar la raíz
negativa pero bueno voy a utilizar la
raíz positiva y vamos a sustituir la en
la ecuación para ver si en efecto me da
0 por lo tanto en mi ecuación original
lo que voy a hacer es cada vez que yo
vea una x sustituirla por la raíz menos
12 veces la raíz de 2 entre 4 y entonces
llegó justo a esto que está aquí 4 entre
4 se van y me queda menos uno más dos
veces la raíz de dos más uno todo esto
elevado al cuadrado menos ocho igual a
cero y menos 11 se van se cancelan por
lo tanto solamente me queda dos veces la
raíz de 2 elevado al cuadrado menos ocho
igual a cero y esto será cierto vamos a
ver vamos a elevar 2 raíz de 2 al
cuadrado elevemos el primero al cuadrado
me va a dar 4
entonces aquí es 4 y la raíz de 2
elevada al cuadrado es 2 y esto es igual
a 0 y 4 por 2 es 8 880 y que creen si se
cumple para la raíz positiva y de igual
manera para la raíz negativa si
sustituye es el valor de la raíz
negativa también te quedaría 0 y por lo
tanto encontramos las raíces y está muy
bien porque ya obtuvimos un nuevo método
para resolver este tipo de problemas de
ecuaciones de segundo grado así que
vamos a ver otro ejemplo pero en este
ejemplo lo que quiero trabajar es que te
des cuenta que tanto en lo que vimos en
los vídeos pasados como lo que estamos
viendo en este vídeo es exactamente lo
mismo así que voy a intentar resolverlo
por las dos maneras tengo x cuadrada
menos 10 x más 25 va a ser igual a 9
esto es mi problema que quiero resolver
a continuación al final toda ecuación de
segundo grado la podemos ver como un
binomio al cuadrado perfecto igual a
otra cosa y bueno vamos a resolverlo
primero por lo que estamos viendo en
este vídeo del lado izquierdo de la
ecuación yo tengo un binomio al cuadrado
perfecto y es que al final cualquier
ecuación de segundo grado la podemos
escribir como un mundo en el cual
perfecto igual a otra cosa no lo olvides
por lo tanto fíjate aquí tengo 25 y aquí
tengo menos 10 dos números que
multiplicados me den 25 y sumados me den
menos 10
esto es x 5 y x-men o si no te das
cuenta o dicho de otra manera tenemos x
5 elevado al cuadrado pues aquí ya tengo
el cuadrado del primero menos dos veces
el primero por el segundo más el
cuadrado del segundo y bueno no olvides
que esto es igual a 9 y ahora sí aquí
voy a despejar a x para esto lo que voy
a hacer es pasar este cuadrado del otro
lado y como lo voy a pasar como raíz
cuadrada o dicho de otra manera lo que
voy a hacer es sacar la raíz cuadrada a
ambos lados de la ecuación y esto es lo
más importante de este vídeo y es lo que
me gustaría enseñarte que las ecuaciones
de segundo grado también las podemos ver
de esta forma por lo tanto voy a sacar
la raíz cuadrada a 9 pero la raíz
cuadrada de 9 es más menos 3 y bueno ya
con esto tengo unas dos reis tres
posibles voy a pasar del otro lado el 5
positivo me va a quedar que x es igual a
5 más menos la raíz de 3 o dicho de otra
manera la primera raíz es 53
es 8 mientras que la otra raíz es 53 que
es 2 en esta ocasión si podemos dar las
raíces de manera explícita y bueno todo
esto porque salía de un binomio cuadrado
perfecto y esto es justo lo que hemos
venido haciendo hasta ahorita lo que
hemos visto en este vídeo pero también
quiero tratar este mismo ejemplo de la
manera que lo habíamos visto en las
ocasiones pasadas y para esto lo que voy
a hacer es igualar esta ecuación a cero
me queda es cuadrada menos 10x y voy a
pasar el 9 del otro lado de la ecuación
para igualarlo a 0 va a pasar con signo
contrario me queda 25 menos 9 lo cual me
da 16 y bueno a continuación voy a
factorizar a este trinomio que yo tengo
aquí busco dos números que multiplicados
me den 16 y que sumados me den menos 10
8 por 2 es 16 y 8 más 2 es 10 pero
tenemos a 10 negativo por lo tanto hay
que poner el factor común y tanto al 8
como al 2 negativos me queda que x 8 por
x 2 es igual a cero o dicho de otra
manera x es igual a 8 x es igual a 2 o x
menos 8 es igual a cero o x menos 2 es
igual a 0 y ya con esto obtenemos las
raíces de esta ecuación
1 grado y qué creés llegamos al mismo
resultado que teníamos resolviendo lo
por el método que acabamos de ver y al
final es importante que tú te adaptes a
un método lo puedes hacer por el método
que tú quieras en este caso lo que
hicimos fue fijarnos en dos números que
multiplicaban nos dieran 16 y sumar los
menos 10 y aquí también es algo parecido
nos fijamos en dos números que
multiplicados medirán 25 y sumados me
dieran unos días lo cuál era un binomio
al cuadrado perfecto pero bueno vamos a
intentar hacer otro ejercicio el último
ejercicio de esta vez va a ser nuestro
pilón para reafirmar todo lo que hemos
visto y este ejercicio espero que lo
hagamos mucho más rápido porque vamos a
intentar hacer la factorización mental
así que vamos a buscar a la siguiente
ecuación cuadrática tengo x cuadrada más
18 x más 81 y esto va a ser igual a am
se me ocurre poner de igual a 1 y bueno
lo que quiero que te des cuenta es que
del lado izquierdo de esta ecuación es
un lindo me el cuadrado perfecto busco
dos números que multiplicados me den 81
y que sumados me den 18 pues esto es x +
9 por x + 9 pues 9 por 9 menos 81 y 9
más
edad 18 y los signos coinciden y dicho
de otra manera x + 9 por x + 9 es x + 9
al cuadrado es decir un binomio al
cuadrado perfecto y bueno yo voy a pasar
el cuadrado del otro lado de la ecuación
como una raíz y me va a quedar la raíz
de 1 que es más menos 1 y después voy a
pasar el 9 del otro lado de la ecuación
como menos 9 y me queda menos 9 más
menos 1 o dicho otra manera menos 9 +1
me da menos 8 esta misma raíz en x es
igual a menos 9 menos 1 lo cual me da
menos 10 y si te das cuenta lo único que
hice fue aplicar el método que
aprendimos en esta ocasión porque
también lo podríamos ver de la siguiente
manera como lo habíamos visto en los
vídeos pasados x cuadrada más 18 x más y
voy a pasar el uno del otro lado
restando me va a quedar 80 y después
buscó dos números que multiplicados me
den 80 y que sumados me den 18 pues esto
es 8 y 10 x más 8 x x más 10 igual a 0 y
esto quiere decir que x es igual a menos
8 o en su dado caso x es igual a menos
10 y obtengo también las dos raíces y ya
con esto estamos preparados para que en
el siguiente vídeo completemos el
binomio al cuadrado perfecto